we're doing a new music marathon on
April fifteenth as part of the festival
of arts science and technology fast
which is celebrating the 150th
anniversary of MIT and it's centered
around several very cutting-edge groups
and individuals all intersecting in
interesting ways so features the kronos
quartet and the bangin account All Stars
which I'm a member and then also Chinese
peapod virtuoso woman and then to MIT
groups gamelan Galactica which is a
Balinese percussion ensemble that that I
direct and the MIT chamber chorus all of
the groups intersect in very interesting
ways and one of the things that we're
trying to do with this concert is make
connections between the groups and bring
combinations together that are
interesting but I've never didn't done
before so the kronos quartet which has
been championing new music for 30 years
did a project with our gamma lon last
year a new piece by Christine southworth
who's an MIT alum and who started a
robot ensemble several years ago called
ensemble robot she came up with an idea
of an electronic gamelan which was then
developed by two other alums Alex
regalis and Laurel pardhu and we did
this project with Chronos super collider
Christine's piece at lincoln center out
of doors so we already had this
connection Chronos came here absolutely
love the whole vibe at MIT loved the
group loved the whole atmosphere and was
very interested in doing more work with
the gamelan and with MIT in general so
they're going to do that piece we also
got them together with todd mac /
composer and musical visionary and now
Todd is making a new piece for them that
features Noam Chomsky's voice and in
fact Noam Chomsky himself because no one
is going to appear on this concert so
those connections were made banga can is
here as part of a three-year ongoing
residency and that which started in the
fall with my opera house in Bali so
they're coming back doing a program of
signature works for
group and then to put it all together we
decided to do this incredibly
forward-thinking piece by Brian Eno
music for airports which bang Anakin has
been touring for some years and to put
all the groups together put bang in a
can with Chronos the two groups have
never played together before and then
add to it woman who is kind of in a way
the link between all the groups because
she's worked with everybody over the
years when she lived in Boston she did
several projects with the gamelan she's
worked with bang on a can she's worked
with Chronos so bringing her in to the
mix and then we needed a chorus so who
better to go to that our own people and
the students of the of the chamber
chorus I think it's a new experience for
them but they're pretty psyched having
worked with students in all sorts of
projects over the years here I've always
seen MIT students completely blend in
with professional musicians in these
kind of occasions and I have no doubt
that's going to be the case this time
too I've always just tried to follow the
MIT model of thinking individually and
following one's own interests and
following through on one's ideas in the
most complete and you know integrated
way one could sometimes that's involved
technology and when that's happened it's
been a great advantage to be here
because there's always lots of people
who know lots more about computers and
about equipment than I do sometimes it's
had nothing to do with technology and
sometimes it comes together as the years
go by a perfect example is what's
happened with the gamelan and these
robot instruments when I started the
balinese gamelan here in 1993 it was
very outside of what one would think and
MIT music program would have it's a
traditional music from another culture
it has nothing to do with anything that
you plug in to anything else or that you
write code to have performed and the one
thing to be said about is that my
colleagues liked the idea immediately
and supported me in doing it immediately
as the years went by the students that
would come into the gamelan would often
be students that had very interesting
musical Minds very interesting musical
imaginations and a lot of them
the same students that would be in the
gamelan would end up going to the media
lab to do course work there or even end
up being graduate students there such as
Alex regardless in tirana cozy you ended
up starting harmonics music and
inventing guitar hero and rockband such
as Laurel pardhu who built these
instruments many many other examples
over the years and at a certain point
you know students would come to me and
say hey would you mind if I tried to
build a little gamelan instrument just
as a project for my you know Becky class
or for something I'm doing at the Media
Lab and so there began to be this
intersection between this very
traditional music and more sort of
traditional MIT activities so things one
of the great things about this place is
that because it's so open and fluid and
because there's not this huge pressure
to kind of say oh well this means this
or this is for this right away I mean
there's room for the imagination to kind
of take hold for the students and four
faculty that I really interesting
fruitful projects develop over time that
you wouldn't expect musical marathons
are great ways to get to know a lot of
music without the pressure of a
90-minute concert every marathon I've
ever been at and I've been to a few you
always find something unexpected that
you really really love come for the you
know stay for women or come for Mulan
and stay for the Eno and either way
you're going to get something
interesting that you didn't you might
not have known about before I'm very
excited to bring these groups together
as part of the fast festival I think
it's the perfect place for it because to
me these groups by themselves represent
something very similar to what fast is
representing music that looks forward
that's rooted in the present but it's
looking to the future and bringing a
venue like fast allowing them to come
together and work together to both bring
what they do really well as well as
forging connections and making new art I
think it's the perfect expression of
everything that i love about MIT and
it's really thrilling for me to have MIT
be hosting this event
you